[MUSIC PLAYING]
FLORINA MUNTENESCU: Hi,
and welcome to I/O live.
I'm Florina
Muntenescu, your host.
And I'm here today with
Sascha Prueter, Director
of Product of Android TV.
SASCHA PRUETER: Hi, Florina.
FLORINA MUNTENESCU:
So tell me, Sascha,
what's new with Android TV?
SASCHA PRUETER: We
have a bunch of stuff
that we are excited to talk,
specifically with developers
at Google I/O, because it is a
developer conference after all.
So we do a lot of
talks and sessions
here about how TV app developers
can actually integrate really
well with Android TV.
So as you can see on
the screen, if I just
stroll around a little
bit, we want app developers
to get their top content and
really beautiful pictures,
all the metadata on screen.
But we want to make sure
it's not only YouTube
or HBO that can do that stuff.
We want every app
developer can do this.
Right?
So we talk a lot
about new ways, how
we can do this
integration really nice,
what ways we have to
help you with this.
And basically, want to enable
developers to have really
the best content on the TV and
make the content really shine.
Because we want to help them
make their apps popular.
And then, obviously,
it's Google I/O.
So we're talking about
Android P as well.
We have a bunch of new stuff
in Android P for users,
but also for developers.
So some examples for users are--
we have a very new set up flow
that gets you all
your favorite apps
already, when you
set up a device.
We have features
like autofill, where
if you have already logged
in on some other device,
you already get your login
credentials on Android TV.
So you don't have to
clumsily enter passwords
with the remote control.
No one likes that, right?
But also they have
cool, new platform APIs
in Android P where,
for example, we
have external camera support.
So you could start to develop
camera apps on TV as well.
That's some of the stuff with
Android P where you can use
the new Android P preview SDK.
It has a TV Emulator,
and you can get
started with it if you want.
FLORINA MUNTENESCU:
I know last year you
launched the Assistant in
the US, but I live in London.
Can I finally use
it in London, also?
SASCHA PRUETER: A
very good question.
Actually, the
international support
for the Google
Assistant on Android TV
is rolling out as we speak.
So specifically, the UK and
some other European countries
rolled out in the
next few weeks.
But since you mentioned
the Assistant,
one really cool thing we
announced here at Google I/O
is our new sound bar project
that we did with JBL.
It's the JBL link bar
that you can see here.
And we really like
the combination
of having a TV device
powering a TV screen,
but with really awesome sound,
and a far-field microphone
built in.
So you don't really need
this remote control anymore.
You can basically
just sit on the sofa
and control your TV
device, or any device
connected to the sound bar.
So you can ask things
like, hey Google.
What's my agenda today?
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Today,
there's only one thing
on your calendar.
It's at 6:00 PM and its
title is, "Pick up the dog".
SASCHA PRUETER: Yeah, I
really shouldn't forget that.
But it's really nice.
You don't have to get
up from the couch, look
for the remote control anymore.
You just talk to your TV
in a very natural way.
Hey, Google, go home.
FLORINA MUNTENESCU: OK, great.
So I can continue losing
my remote control.
But still, I'm an
Android developer.
So what can I do practically?
Is there some code that
I can already write?
SASCHA PRUETER: You could
download the Android P Preview
SDK with your Emulator,
but we know developers want
to work with real hardware.
So one really cool thing we are
announcing here at Google I/O
is the ADT-2 Developer Device.
For those of you who
have been developing
for Android TV for a
while, might remember
we had a ADT-1 Developer
Device in 2014,
launched at Google I/O.
And after four years,
we thought, it's time
to do that again.
So it's a neat little
Android TV dongle
you can connect to your TV.
You can sign up for this.
We have a sign-up form live.
And we are selecting--
it's a limited
edition device, but we
make sure a lot of developers
are getting one of those.
It's a real cool small
Android TV dongle,
voice-enabled remote control.
So all the things we've
been talking about,
content integration, Assistant
integration for your apps,
you can try that all
out on the device.
FLORINA MUNTENESCU: Great.
Thank you very much, Sascha.
So we already have a lot of
new things for Android TV--
both for developers
and for end users.
So now all we need to do
is check out the developer
documentation and also
sign up for the dongle.
Thank you, Sascha.
SASCHA PRUETER: Thank you.
FLORINA MUNTENESCU: This
is Florina for I/O live.
[MUSIC PLAYING]